ja ich berichte seit drei Jahren über
die Pandemie begleite die Impfstoffe
seit von Beginn an und ich hätte ehrlich
gesagt nicht gedacht dass mich noch
etwas überraschen kann bei den
Impfstoffen das hat es aber dann doch
ich konnte nämlich viele Dokumente
einsehen Protokolle zu Forschung mit
vielen
Kandidaten sprechen die diese Impfstoffe
getestet haben auch Studienleiter und so
weiter und all das hat sich
zusammengesetzt zu einem Bild
das nun ergibt dass während der
Zulassungsstudie doch viele
ungeranntheiten auftauchen das geht los
damit dass schwere impfen Nebenwirkungen
die tatsächlich aufgetreten sind
offenbar verheimlicht wurden auch
vertuscht wurden diese ganzen Fälle
werfen Fragen auf wenn neue
gesundheitsrelevante Produkte auf den
Markt kommen müsste man da nicht besser
gehen und Kind schauen